[Music]
dear mom dear mom dear mom thank you my
adopted mom she handles every situation
you throw at her with such grace and she
comes out of it stronger than ever she
has the kindest heart and the most
compassionate soul and she's just
beautiful on the inside and out and if I
could be half the woman that she is
whenever I grow up I've done something
right with my life we don't share the
same skin or the same eyes we don't
share the same smile or the same laugh
we don't share the same nose for the
same taste in most things but I am
absolutely 100% unequivocally Who I am
because of you despite my mom and I at
not sharing any DNA she passed down to
me her love for animals and the fact
that we're both very allergic to all of
them on the outside we look like
strangers
journeying this life to
but on the inside on the mall I am every
time you looked at me and told me that I
was chosen I'm every time that I wanted
to give up
I'm every time I felt unwanted and you
looked me in the eye and said you are
mine emolument our relationship was born
from a place of loss and there's
something we will always breathe and yet
through all of the uncertainty all the
meltdowns all the times that I thought
you would quit her name because that's
all kids like me have known you've seen
me through we found each other later in
life which means we missed out on a lot
of first my mom is pretty amazing
she was the field trip coordinator at my
elementary school she took me to get my
first prom dress and she even went to my
bachelorette party with me which was
pretty rad I will always think of her as
my mom she is my mom and she will always
be my mom
no first breasts our first words no
first steps or first dance recitals but
it's okay instead we get to spend the
rest of our lives creating new firsts
there's things getting together or the
first time I stayed the night at your
house I felt a sense of safety or our
first Christmas when you got me that
pink fur blanket that I still sleep with
till this day thank you our first are
different than most but are beyond
special to me you saying yes loving me
has taught me that biology is the least
of what makes someone anything
you've taught me that family isn't a
choice and out of all the people in the
world I'm so glad that you chose me we
don't share a single strand of DNA but
the presence of that wouldn't change
anything about what we have you are so
absolutely 100% unequivocally still my
mom and even if I tried I could not have
dreamed of a better mother than you I
love you mommy happy Mother's Day
[Applause]
[Music]